- [Voiceover] In the last video we began
to see some pretty good evidence
that DNA was the molecular
basis for inheritance
and we saw that from the work of Avery,
McCarthy and McLead where
they tried to identify
whether it was DNA or proteins that acted
as a transformation principle
in Griffith's experiments
and I encourage you to watch that video
if all of this sounds unfamiliar.
But even their work in 1944
was not viewed as conclusive evidence.
It was viewed as strong evidence,
but not conclusive evidence because,
remember how they did it,
they took the heat killed smooth strain,
the smooth strain you might remember
from Griffith's experiment
was the virulent one.
The heat killed it.
When you heat kill it in injected amounts,
it didn't do anything to the mouse,
but if you took the heat
killed smooth strain
and put it with the rough strain,
it somehow transformed the rough strain
in to the smooth strain,
in to the virulent strain and so
they took the heat killed smooth strain
and they took out its different components
and they eventually were able to isolate
one that was able to
transform the rough strain
in to the smooth strain by itself
and then they applied all
sorts of chemical tests to it
and said, "Hey, there's
pretty good evidence
"that this is DNA,"
but it wasn't conclusive because, well,
maybe they didn't purify it properly
or maybe there was still
a little bit of protein.
Maybe it was mostly DNA, but maybe it was
a little bit of protein
that was still left there
that actually did the transformation.
So the scientific community,
they weren't just saying,
"Hey, that looks pretty good,
"Let's move on, let's just assume."
They wanted to continue to test it
and especially test it in different ways.
And, the conclusive evidence didn't come
until a few years later, until 1952
when Alfred Hershey and Martha Chase
decided to study T2 bacterio phage.
Let me write this down.
T2 bacterio phage,
this is phage that infects bacteria.
Bacterio
phage.
When you hear the word phage,
we're referring to viruses.
Now they knew that T2 bacterio phage
was composed of proteins and DNA
and they didn't, well, we now know,
that it's a protein shell
and there's DNA inside,
but they, from their
point of view, they said,
"Okay, it's made up and if we try to
"look at the stuff that
this virus is made of,
"it's protein and DNA."
So protein plus DNA,
and they knew that this virus,
when it infects bacteria,
it injects something into that bacteria.
So it injects something
and that something is what
hijacks that bacteria's
genetic information
to start producing more
of the T2 bacterio phage.
So they could identify the
something that gets injected.
If they could figure out
if that something was
either a protein or a virus,
then they would have conclusively proven
so sorry,
if they could show that something
was not protein or virus,
if it was protein or DNA,
if they could show that it
was either protein or DNA,
then they could show conclusively
that it's either the protein or the DNA
that forms the molecular basis
and so they're actually quite sceptical
of Avery, McCarthy and
MacLead's experiments.
They actually, Hershey and Chase,
actually thought that they were gonna show
that it was the protein,
and remember, this whole
time people were like,
"Protein, we know it's
these complex molecules
"that have these different shapes
"and all these different amino acids.
"It seems like that's
much more likely to encode
"the complexity of genetic
information than DNA."
They didn't have an
appreciation for the structure
of DNA at this time.
So they devised an
experiment to figure out
what is that something
that the T2 bacterio phage is infecting.
Is that something protein?
Is it protein
or
DNA?
So this is the question.
So what they do is
they take two batches or
they developed two batches
of T2 bacterio phage.
One batch of the T2 bacterio phage
they do it in the presence
of radioactive phosphorus,
phosphorus 32.
In the other batch, I should say
they grow that T2 bacterio phage
in the process of another
radioactive isotope,
but this time it is of sulfur.
This is sulfur 35.
So why are they doing that?
Well phosphorus is found in DNA.
So in this first batch,
the radioactive marker, you could say,
is going to incorporate
itself into the DNA.
In the second batch, sulfur is found
in the protein and not in the DNA
and so this would actually
tag the protein parts.
And if you're wondering, well,
how do you develop these
radioactive batches,
well, you let the viruses hijack cells
in a medium that has either
the radioactive sulfur
or the radioactive phosphorus
and as they reproduce,
they are going to incorporate
that radioactive material
into either the protein or
the DNA of the new viruses
that get produced.
So anyway, they were able to produce some
of the T2 bacterio phage in the presence
of the radioactive phosphorus
and they knew that way that the DNA
would get that radioactive material in it
and then with the radioactive sulfur
they said the protein would
have that radioactive sulfur.
And then for each of those batches,
they then infected
bacterio phage with them
and they said, okay, they're
going to inject something
in to the bacterio phage,
and to figure out what
that something is that was
injected in to the bacterio phage
they take the products in
either of the two scenarios,
they first blend 'em up so that all
of the stuff that's left outside
gets taken off of the
surface of the bacteria cells
and then they stick it in to a centrifuge
and the centrifuge is, you can imagine,
it's kind of just a big spinning machine.
If you were to take a test
tube and take it sideways,
one way to think about it,
put it sideways like this.
Put maybe a stopper in it so nothing leaks
and then you spin it
around really, really,
really, really fast,
what you're going to find,
you can actually generate
significant g forces
and so the heavier stuff
is going to gravitate
to the bottom of the
test tube or to the right
when it is on its side,
and the lighter stuff
is going to gravitate
to the left.
And, it turns out that the bacteria,
the actual bacterial cells,
those are heavier so the bacterial cells
are going to go towards
the bottom of the test tube
and they're gonna form a material
that we call the pellet
and then all of the other stuff,
all of the fluid and
the leftover phage parts
those are going to go up to the top
of the test tube and we
call that the supernatent.
I always have trouble pronouncing that.
Supernatent.
And so they said, "Look,
if we look at the pellet,"
which they knew had the
bacterial cells int here
or you could even say the
remnants of the bacterial cells,
"if the pellet here
"contains phosphorus,
that means that the DNA,
"our radioactive DNA or our tagged DNA
"made it in to the bacteria,
"but if it contains sulfur,
that means that the protein
"made it in to the bacteria."
And, what they found is
they found that the radioactive
phosphorus
was in the pellet which
allowed them to conclude
that, hey, it's the DNA from the virus
that made it inside of the bacteria
and not the protein
and then they said, "Well, it must be!
"Wow, the Avery, McCarthy
and Maclead were correct.
"It's actually the DNA that is
this transformation principle
"that can go in and hijack the genetic,
"the machinery of the bacteria
"to produce more of the actual virus,
"so this is a really,
really, really big deal."
Once again, we started with
Mendel saying, "Hey, we have
these inheritable factors
"and they seem to segregate
and sort in certain ways.
"They seem to be discrete."
Bover and Sutton said, "Hey,
"chromosomes seem to kind of,
"their behavior during meiosis
"when cells split
"seem to kind of match up to that."
Morgan starts to provide some evidence.
We have Griffith's
experiments with the mice
and the bacteria and saying, "Hey, look,
"there's some transformation principle."
Avery, McCarthy and MacLeod say, "Hey,
"looks like when we try to really purify
"this transformation principle,
"it seems like DNA is
what really matters."
And then Hershey and Chase validate that
even more conclusively.